you said to me one time you were like I
think I'm you even though we're friends
you're like I think I'm parasocial with
you guys yeah it's so weird cuz like
I I get so much of your content like
Conor every single day trash taste like
a lot of times in the week I watch more
trash taste than a normal viewer cuz I
go through multiple times like I manage
so much I'm like it's so hard cuz I I I
feel like I'm here or
like I don't understand how this works
what technically friend we talk like
outside of likeu but also I feel like I
know more about you and I can never like
position myself there I know sometimes
Joy's being like Oh yeah yeah we should
like catch up like let's have a call I'm
like I I know what you
did I don't we don't need to talk I
don't need it I already know everything
I've already talked to you in my mind
I'll I'll be honest you have nothing to
say to me yeah I'll be honest I actually
feel the exact same way when I see like
these boys's content when like doing
something else it it feels weird I don't
know like I remember watching your video
with Anthony Pilla and I'm just like
this feels
weird yeah I'm like I don't know it was
it was like super weird just seeing you
go through like this interview and yeah
I was watching that video and I was just
like I already know this yeah yeah well
yeah I I it's hard when I do interviews
now cuz I'm like how cuz it's obviously
the interviews appeal to my audience
right but then it's also you're trying
to make it so that uh Anthony or
whoever's audience is also aware but in
my head I'm like man I just it's
impossible to give anything any more to
people who know me yeah I already say
everything I mean that's what happens
when we have what like 100 hours of us
just we're nearly at 200 episodes like I
can't possibly do an interview that will
be like
interesting yeah so like anyone who
watched the Anthony P you're like you
just getting the the rehash you're just
getting like the the breakdown pretty
much um so yeah I guess yeah but but
also sometimes I feel like I don't know
it's Maybe dirty is the wrong word but
it just feels wrong because we know each
other we we know each other and if if
there's a part of that video where you
haven't mentioned to me I'm like I
should have asked him about that yeah
just be like why did you hide this from
us why do I not I should know
everything I think mud know is a
literally everything about me yeah it is
like think knows everything about us
yeah pretty much CU I yeah we have trash
taste and then you have all of my main
and second Channel you know literally
everything I do in my life no no that's
that's not a thing that's I feel like I
feel like the real thing is seeing the
like the footage that goes in between
like the highlights and everything
that's got you see us you see us at our
best and our worst see when we're on and
when we're
off and I think that's the biggest thing
where I realized that you know Mudan
sees everything that we film on the
specials uh that he chooses not to put
in the video which uh is is a lot
there's a lot of footage out there there
been a lot of videos that I filmed and I
have left that day being like holy [__]
I did awful I was just not funny I
didn't I wasn't there and then Mudan
sends me the edit and I'm like okay it's
okay and then I had voice over and I
watch it and I'm like huh maybe I am
funny it seems like I I had a lot of fun
but I distinctly remember I didn't have
fun doing this um to be real like all
your off are still pretty good like I've
edited for some people who are literally
doing it for content and they're like
yeah so we're going to we're going to do
this and then when it cuts it's like
[__] what scrip again [__] I hate this
so much like literally 180 and I'm like
w that's awful I think honestly that's
that's shooting in Japan cuz I think uh
when the cameras turn off in Japan
especially if you're doing stuff um on a
location with other people espcially
Japanese people you it's so bizarre cuz
there's always this level of like
profession you have to maintain I notic
that like uh if I behave too differently
to camera and then when the camera cuts
and the energy changes I I feel
sometimes they get confused they're like
they don't understand like what I'm
doing because they don't understand what
I'm saying so sometimes if I'm talking
in English and my energy is totally
different I think sometimes people are
like H it's this weird vibe I got and so
I try to always like keep when I go in
there I'm giving them the same energy
that throughout I don't know why I I
subconsciously do this but yeah I just
something I just kind of picked up doing
I I got a lot when like filming with
Japanese people um I I get like a thing
a lot where people like wow you're like
exactly the same off camera and I'm like
are you not like what are you doing
that's like so different cuz like I've
had so many I'm always not going to name
the shows but like a few Japanese shows
I went on it was like it was as you said
it was like a full 180 with some people
where it's like when they're on camera
they're just like the most like [__]
gearos like most extravagant like loud
and like personality type thing the
moment like someone's like all right cut
they just
like bring me my latte you know like
it's it's like that level I wish we had
someone to bring lates oh that's called
Uber Eats yeah the Uber Eats guy does do
it yeah he does it comes and clutch that
one guy definitely definitely knows who
we are delivering our Uber Eats thank
you for keeping it a secret but yeah
there's so many YouTubers who are like
completely
180 who even edited for see guys we're
real we're real you should with us
you'll be happy to know we're exactly
the same more paral we are everything
you see on camera is us 100% we are not
bullshitting
anything God I hate that you're
[Music]
true D I was like I really want to add
the
window at the window at the
window right actually right he's a real
one we a real one he's telling the truth
well cuz I I had I had this distinct
thing and I I I had this um when I was
doing like the Sebastian stuff I had
this this this fear that people would
think I wasn't
smart and I don't know why I was scared
that people would think I was Dumb and
so I would never ever try to say
anything that was even remotely fact
checkable or anything like that I would
just keep it and I would limit where I
would appear cuz I was like man I just
don't want to talk about me cuz I know
I'm [__] dumb uh and if I talk and
open my mouth and i r for 10 minutes I'm
going to say something stupid wow trash
tastes really changed absolutely and
then after a while I was like man it's
exhausting like having to like be
careful about what I'm saying all the
time like keeping the act up right well
you kind of playing almost like a
character um that's how we get the best
Clips what me just saying dumb [__] no I
know that now like I know that like it's
more entertaining when I'm just just
being me the whole reason why you know
that's the secret to trash day yeah and
and then I realized I was like oh my God
I can I I also enjoy being on camera
more I also enjoy content more I I think
the the videos are better off for it
when I just embrace the fact that I'm
sometimes just I just do dumb stuff and
I say dumb things I think that's okay
and I think that works for the show as
well because like you know a lot of
people will watch that and being like
you know cuz like that's something you
would experience in your day-to-day life
with your friends right like sure you'll
have that like one super smart dude
who's always right about everything but
most of the time people are dumb as [__]
and they just make [__] up and that's
what's funny black black paint bro it's
just heavy it black paint until you
start talking physics and stuff then
it's no my favorite is the polit not
Politics the
philosophy you Sayes invented he
invented philes invented philosophy my
favorite no my favorite one is the not
my I said that Pokemon was the most
Googled thing in 1996 or something oh
yeah and it was just Google wasn't made
in wasn't invented it was
2000 oh my God yeah I just I just want a
montage of like trash taste explains
stuff really [__] badly like like me
explaining the logarithmic scale or
whatever oh my God that was the one was
has there ever been a video that any of
us have done uh where you thought what a
[__] dumb idea when we you like got
the video and then you edited it and it
turned out like huh you can be honest
this is like I there's so many there's
so many I can say it out loud now
finally yeah finally I don't think that
has been you just do like normal stuff
like even
if it's like very basic it can still be
edited to be a good video cuz like the
the base content around it is pretty
decent MH so like even if you do like
the most basic things in Japan is like
fine yeah yeah what about the Nick
Museum you like the oh that was great
that was fun I wish I could have used
more kind of [__] though cuz like yeah
oh everything needs to be censored
actually we can't show anything I sent
him a message for like so yeah I went to
this thing and I really want to include
in the YouTube video but you need to
Mosaic everything but me like like
onethird of the video was just dicks
everywhere on screen all time it's all
dicks and then I I cut it out initially
like Danny did and uh then he was like
no can have some of it in yeah you could
include I was like you got to include
some of it this she's wild and then to
actually show it it was just him and
kaho's face unblurred everything else
was censored the entire frame well
that's like me when I went hentai
shopping right it was like it was I got
to one floor and I'm just like M on you
have to sense [__] everything why you
even do
this I think it's fun to see
the just the sheer amount of [__] that
needs to be blured it kind of gives you
a a good perspective of like oh wow
there is just dick everywhere